[Music]
who's your celebrity look like a little
bit like Jimmy Fallon I've been told I
look like Natalie Portman and Anne
Hathaway had a baby no I think I just
look like me really I don't think I
really look like anyone else I would say
rosario Dawson Jack's her sons anarchy
anyone else Leonardo DiCaprio yeah my
celebrity look-alike is and then some
people kind of sometimes say I look like
I'm a Miss Deborah - I don't even listen
to her music but I pulled up her
Instagram when I was like that could be
like that could be my third sister a
little bill when I was younger and then
Dwight Howard recently do you agree with
that little bill maybe I've been told I
look like Deb from Dexter oh yeah like a
hot cousin Nick Jonas so a lot of people
tell you that yeah
do you agree with it no I've been told I
look a lot like little Dicky I've been
told that my celebrity look like is
stephane current like I could be his
daughter Stefan crazy daughter but I
don't see it especially after I dyed my
hair you know it's not blonde anymore I
get told that I look like Seth
MacFarlane a lot I get a lot of like
Tiger Woods also get Miguel often I
think that's about it really though very
good childish game you know oh yeah best
the other one how could I like how could
I forget about good old Donald uh that's
my favorite one actually do you agree
with that one the moon I would like to
is it a handsome guy you know I mean
Alicia Keys to some extent not today I
don't know like her right now but back
in the day you look like maybe my cousin
Lucy famous yeah he's pretty Michelle
Richard Grieco
what is he best known for why made Bobby
30 movies you know some people say
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Khaleesi
Adam Devine a lot of people tell me that
I believe it meant is from guardians of
the galaxy Tom Selleck yeah I mean not
really but that's what I'm going for
that's why I'm going out there's
mustache I'm wearing this nice wine sure
is so that way I could look like the
black Tom Selleck so black magnum p.i
coming at you I would say Jenaya eco
people say when I do this I look like
Thor what's that I don't know do I
I've been told I look like Thor but a
lot of a young Janet Jackson so I've
heard a lot of different things I think
kind of anyone who's like brown and
racially ambiguous so I've gotten Amory
the singer from the 90s I've gotten
kailani
from San Francisco another singer
someone once said that I looked like
Aaliyah and so I was Aaliyah for
Halloween like two years ago I looked
totally different I had a wig on and
that helped and then I just bought this
like Tommy Phil Hilfiger top and bottom
which is what she's wearing in wonder
for album covers so that helped
detective Lance from the arrow I don't
know the actor's name but I was working
a bar mitzvah and all these little kids
came up to me with a pole and he showed
me the toy oh hey that is really funny
and I look like this guy I get told at
least five times a day I look exactly
like samuel l.jackson I don't really see
it but
I'll take it the girl that plays Hannah
Baker and their teens why Michael Cera
who's on Arrested Development and super
bad my friends tell me that and every
once in a while a stranger will will
tell me I look like him Tina Turner
who's your celebrity look like Mark
Ruffalo currently I don't think I really
have one but one time this dad type came
up to me and told me I look like a young
Linda run dad I was like I will make out
with you right now be like nothing of
life but it was like the hottest thing
anybody's ever said to me I think my
celebrity look-alike is Masson day from
Game of Thrones I used to go to
breakfast and the cashier would always
be like have you sort of Game of Thrones
yet you look just like the girl from
Game of Thrones I'm like no I don't
watch it and then I started watching it
and I was like oh I do kind of maybe
with the hair I think that day people
have told me that I look like steve-o
without my beard so if you picture me
without a beard maybe like five years
younger
chilli she's a member in TLC Chris Pratt
that crisp ride not necessarily
star-lord but I do have a couple
customers at Vons that call me a Star
Wars Episode the guy from everyone hates
Chris like my hair is a little long now
but like the facial features you know
it's there
a young Jane Seymour everybody said I
look like I the tiger or John Lizzie and
I don't look I don't see it I don't look
like neither those been at all I like I
look like myself I've been told it looks
like bigger Marie Kondo so I mean I like
that I mean I like to organize my life
so I mean that's pretty fitting Robert
Redford you get done a lot in airports
yeah do you agree with it no no I wish
very good-looking man
Blueface all right so I've been told my
celebrity like is a UFC welterweight
champion Georges st. Pierre apparently
it's Seth Rogen
I don't see it but every time I tell the
people they say oh yeah I totally see
that so I don't know Angelina Jolie
people tell me I look like Cameron Diaz
canneries supposedly I don't know
do you agree with it I don't know I
don't think so
I've been told by some people that I
look like Keanu Reeves or some people
say John wick so I don't know you know I
have been told that I look like Keanu
Reeves I don't really know
that's what other people like pink or I
don't feel like I do but I guess I'd
look at myself every day so I don't
really like I don't I don't see the
correlation but I that's what I've been
told so I guess I just go with it I
suppose everyone before you go I just
wanna let you know that I put together a
playlist of episodes similar to the one
you just watched
so if you liked this episode make sure
to check that out it'll be linked
somewhere on the screen I also just want
to thank you guys for everything it's
pretty crazy how far we've come in just
two years and I can't believe I get to
do this every week you know it's a it's
a lot of fun making these episodes but
most of the fun is in getting to share
it with you guys because you guys are
just the coolest and I love hearing what
you have to say about each episode yeah
I can't thank you guys enough so thank
you again that's pretty much it I'll see
you guys next week